ophelia enchaîne trois heures de
répétition de rock acrobatique
elle est venue de bordeaux passer ses
vacances au festival darc ce stage lui
permet de découvrir des danses
différentes et finalement ces vacances
ne sont pas si reposante
cette danse de salon ensuite une pause
ragga jam lâchant un peu trop copieux
comme programme c'est la première année
qu'on fait 4 et ouais ça fait beaucoup
je pense que si tu regardes l'année
prochaine après que deux ou trois puis
direction le camping pour la pause
déjeuner à quelques minutes des salles
de cours c'est l'hébergement le plus
pratique et le moins cher pour les
stagiaires
katherine la mère d'aurélien kaminis
agnès et jean louis un ami ont décidé de
passer deux semaines de vacances à
châteauroux tous les quatre sont le
stage il coûte 450 euros par personne
c'est un choix est avant tout un plaisir
moi je pratique le tango tout au long de
l'année et
mais venir ici c'est c'est vraiment les
vacances à ces trois ans que je viens et
du coup je commençais à avoir mes
habitudes dans l'écho donc voilà je
retrouve mes amis et tu fais quoi comme
quoi je fais ragga jam danse africaine
et cette année j'ai commencé à la salsa
et danses de salon si on défie s'amuse
on s'amuse
il ya une palette d'activités proposées
qui est tellement vaste que chacun peut
y trouver son compte
pas le temps de faire la sieste c'est
déjà l'heure de la répétition des danses
de salon c'est la seule discipline où
tous peuvent se retrouver
c'est pas si jeune
malgré la chaleur et l'effort il
enchaîne les différentes variations dans
des styles très différents
chacha on a du temps devant nous est de
taille
on a quatre danseuses de sympa aussi
dans les danses de salon il ya une
variété ça change sans arrêt c'est
d'autre attitude et c'est hyper vivant
c'est très gai donc ça enfants pas
fatigué quand on en fait et ce ne sera
pas leur dernière répétition le premier
filage du spectacle a lieu ce soir à
partir de 21h sur la scène et il se
poursuivra jusque tard dans la nuit